when you go for gender equity what you
want is well you want the facade right
you want fifty fifty percent fifty
percent here and fifty percent there men
and women it doesn't matter if they're
competent if they want to work there and
we have government bodies regulating
this and trying to and we do this from
kindergarten and upwards can you talk
about how this is related to sort of how
men are treated or at least talked about
in Sweden because you guys have the
first supposedly self proclaimed
feminist government right yes that's
what even though as you could tell when
the visitors Aron day all wars nicob so
very feminist indeed very but but the
reason I mentioned that is because I as
I said earlier I did both of your
podcasts which will link to below
because I want people to see you guys as
hosts but I mentioned the story to both
of you of how the day of the Stockholm
shows it was cold out and I wanted to
get a hat and I went into H&M which is
your is that your great well HS like gap
here yeah are your greatest export and I
went into H&M and I was on line to buy
the Hat and ice the guy in front of a
young guy probably 20 21 years old says
to the cashier this is the first suit
I've ever bought he was speaking in
English so the first suit I've ever
bought and and I'm going to see this
Jordan Peterson show tonight and then
the cashier says I'm going to see the
Jordan beaters in show tonight so I
tapped the guy on the shoulder I turn
her I said I'm going to see the Jordan
beaters that show and he knew who I was
and I just thought it was such an
incredible moment like this young kid
who literally was buying the first suit
of his life to as you just said listen
to a Canadian psychology professor tell
him to sit up straight with his
shoulders tab so can you talk a little
bit about what's happening with either
young people or men or both well we've
had there's a problem with language
because what I think they're trying to
do in Sweden have been trying for my
entire life is they're trying to
accomplish gender equity and that's not
the same thing as a quality of the sexes
right because you guys have equality of
the sexes in many senses right well that
depends on what you mean with quality
yes you have the same opportunities in
some cases women even have more
opportunities economically when it comes
to subsidies for the
pregnant for instance we take the
results maternity leave the results of
the free choices that women make are
though considered a problem yes right so
this is the this is the interesting wait
but just to be clear though because what
part of what I said
no no but when you when you go for
gender equity what you want is well you
want the facade right you want fifty
fifty percent fifty percent here and
fifty percent they're men and women it
doesn't matter if they're competent if
they want to work there and we have
government bodies regulating this and
trying to and we do this from
kindergarten and upwards we encourage
the girls to take up more space and be
less like girls and we encourage the
boys to you know close in words and not
take up as much space to so basically
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to make these kids go against
their biology or whatever they feel is
right because they want it to look
perfect so to be clear it's not just an
equal or address right it's not just you
know you should act this way but it ends
up working into how what jobs they
choose because Jordan mentioned it
several times there and a lot of people
talk about this that you because you
guys have had equality for so long
meaning you could do whatever you want
as a man or a woman
it turned out that yes women tend to be
nurses more in men turn out to be
engineers more because women generally
are more interested in people and men
happen to be more interested in things
that's just the nature of reality a
gender power of what you were getting to
the social justice worries don't like
that experiment they don't like the
experiment of freedom jordan was on a
talk show host in sweet or on a talk
show in sweden where he was addressing
this very topic and he basically said
well you know science supports that this
is the way it happens in a free country
where people can choose and we had like
one of the top level politicians there
and she was well i don't agree with that
and you know I was just flower I
actually made a you know an episode on
my show about that because like this man
just that society science says this I
don't agree with it okay so what what
are we now mystics yeah but so that
thing though so the the politician says
that I don't agree
I don't agree with what science says I
don't agree with what biology says we
all know that men or women are different
it doesn't make either sex better than
the other it just it's just an is but
when you hear that response you think
most people just swallow that and take
it I think most people do that because
we're a fiercely egalitarian very
conformist people so they have been
trained for very long to just accept
that form of communication now we have a
you know a government body the Ministry
of equality and I mean just the name
sounds like so totalitarian I can't you
know it's like an 84 totally and they
have the authority to look at like all
companies and other governmental bodies
schools universities everything
everything has to be gender mainstream
and is all run by women there are only
women working at the so we're right so
when you do this then as a private
business man how does that affect you
you know funny thing is like when I when
my youtube-channel started taking off my
business partner he was like okay what's
happen what's going on this might
actually hurt our business interests and
I said well you know if we start seeing
some some you know disasters happening
because of what I'm saying online we'll
have a conversation and say okay so we
tried it for a while turns out business
is booming because now people are there
you know finding me just because they
see my video so I want to work with your
company mm-hmm so even though we have
all these enemies now there are some
people I wouldn't want to work with
anyway right what about on the hiring
side though I mean when you're actually
hiring people you have to look at that
those immutable characteristics to
figure out who you're gonna hire well I
don't handle the recruiting anymore
personally so I've kind of removed
myself my face from that a bit I don't
think it's much of a problem because
Sweden has a general problem when it
comes to recruiting talented people we
don't have enough of them we have a lot
of people that are going you know
subsidies and various government
programs loads but I mean IT recruiting
you know very smart IT professionals
that's that's generally very difficult
although I find I have quite a few of
them you know these software guys that
are quite libertarian so no I don't see
it
problem.the you know that here's another
you know thing I'd like to mention
you're not allowed to ask people
anything you want when you hire them in
Sweden so when I first started out with
my company I would ask people so are you
in any unions because I don't want any
unionized people in my companies and
then my HR eventually you got to stop
saying that and Rick it's illegal you
cannot ask them if they're unionized so
now we we have a text and when we
recruit which is kind of like are you
very collecting a collectivistic Lee
minded person this might not be the
place for you yeah I mean this is
happening everywhere I think it does
hurt kids because if you raise an entire
generations of girls telling them that
they are beautiful and we can strong at
the same time and can do no wrong well
you're turning them into sexist fascists
basically and you're telling all the
boys that they are inherently evil
that's and we've been doing this for a
long time now so is that the part that's
particularly perverse about this so you
take a society you make them equal then
at the same time because you know that
humans are gonna have individual
emotions you keep you keep telling the
the male's that they're evil despite the
fact that you and Sweden have done more
for equality than virtually anybody so
it's all it's really like it's just
never enough because actually as you
guys know what they don't what they want
is not really equality it's no
informative and I've been trying to tell
them that this would be as if someone
came out as gay and you told them no
suppress that right because that's what
you're telling the boys like oh you feel
the need to run around and play football
suppress it and in telling the girls
like you're playing with dolls bad girl
go out and play football now before the
haters get in here and say Oh Aaron flam
doesn't want boys to play with Barbies
you actually are perfectly okay I never
played football I I was not the type are
you a huge Barbie collection which
permit a period is a bit much III was
into hidden Star Wars figurines or the
action figure yes you call them that to
make them sound more manly but they're
basically dolls I'll show you my claim
yeah
we're out here alright let's shift a
little bit because you mentioned
actually that you lived it I believe
you're moving
yes I can say that in Malmo now we hear
a lot about Malmo on a certain side of
the internet where they report on a lot
of bombings and stabbings and all these
weird things coming out of Malmo now we
only hear of this from sort of right but
I would say not just center-right but
more right-leaning things outlets in
America and then anyone that reports on
them says that they're racist in their
bigoted and the rest of it you live in
Malmo what happened in Malmo and just
tell me a little bit about the history
of Malmo before any of Malmo it's in the
deep south of Sweden so it's a port city
this is where basically everyone that's
coming to Sweden you know by foot or by
car they will enter across a bridge and
they come into Malmo so we have a very
large number of you know refugees and so
forth from the you know crisis of 2015
and Malmo is it's always been a rather
poor City and I used it these two big
big ships there and in the 1980s that
old collapsed and everyone was an
alcoholic for a while then it kind of
became slightly better but it's it's a
lost making city and it's it's been run
by socialists for you know better part
of the last hundred years now over time
crime in mama started to rise
uncontrollably if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues instead of
non-stop yelling check out our
international playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlists there all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell